a comment and you're like oh so we're
allowed to do this right to you right
you're like oh we're we're saying that
this is okay the r word right yeah oh
you're like how do you know we drink
right imagine if a guy right imagine if
I have a girlfriend I'm just like oh I
got drunk I hooked up with her I got Ard
right
we don't allow men to do that in this
culture women are the only people that
are allowed to go and do ignorant things
or act a certain way as an adult and
then say oh I was coerced oh I was under
the influence oh this oh that we don't
allow grown men to do that I agree with
you and you ought to be and I'm shocked
no but I agree I think women in a lot of
ways it's like okay to mention hey I've
been you know hurt inappropriately but
then for men for a man to come out and
say I've been hard everyone's like oh no
like men have mental health issues as
well yes like there's a lot of unhealed
trauma Trauma from childhood from lack
of mom there lack of a dad and so I
would I do consider myself a feminist
but I also do men need support men need
mental health and there's nothing wrong
with being a feminist all men are not
misogynistic some at this table might be
but men needs that support men need that
hey it's okay that you know men are
struggle with anxiety men are told to
bottle up their feelings
most men you can go cry in the closet
just don't cry in public right now I let
it out just not in front of you it's not
okay but it's still bottling it why then
then why is it that men feel so scared
to go to therapy because they don't want
to be vulnerable they've been told to
not be vulnerable in public that's not
in public that's a one-on-one session
okay but unfortunately there are men out
there that have been told that just
seeking help is a sign of weakness I see
I asked a guy that's actually going to
therapy I want to note on this um a lot
of guys don't go to therapy because we
avoid anything that has to do the doctor
if I fell and broke my wrist uh I'm such
a little [ __ ] that I would put it off
for a week before I go to the hospital
and that's just for some reason men are
like this for some reason we just want
to put it off as long as we can or avoid
his doctors
it's just it's just a man thing but it
also goes into mental health yeah too
but it's more about man we're just
focused on our [ __ ] sometimes like
sometimes I'm really focused on other
[ __ ] and I don't care about this little
injury there's a little [ __ ] thing
or whatever it is we especially when you
have to be a provider and you have a lot
of responsibilities on your on your [ __ ]
you can't be crying over a scraped knee
you know what I'm saying so and that's
why a lot of guys don't do it to
piggyback off of that I think that men
should feel empowered and confident
enough to be able to seek help no matter
if they're if it's the knee or if it's
the Mind you'd be surprised though how
often because our problems aren't that
bad you can literally talk to another
guy usually or a family member or
something to solve whatever that issue
is that's making you sad and that's the
problem that's why I think a lot of guys
also avoid therapies because usually
it's just a financial issue it's just
something stupid that's getting you down
in the moment but but we're supposed to
nothing
but we're supposed to come up with
Solutions as men that is our job to
always come to a solution exactly and so
sometimes you don't need to go pay money
to somebody that's gonna wants you to
stay bad because he's going to keep
making more money every time you come
back to the doctor's office not a good
one uh like you're writing on a good one
but a lot of them you know aren't
every therapist like person that I know
that's becoming a therapist is bad [ __ ]
crazy and I'm like I cannot believe
they're going to be a
therapists and everyone's not and I've
had so many people go to therapy and
they come back crazier I'm not saying it
doesn't work it does they literally go
buy a book for some people but that
breaks my heart
I love you Christina you'll never see
this could you guys let her talk to you
go again I'm sorry it is mainly because
like therapists they can't give you any
like personal advice that like he said
your friends can actually they know your
situation they can actually give you
like in-depth advice whereas like your
therapist is going by like their DS and
a lot of times I feel like like if you
go to your friends they actually know
the context and kind of how you are in a
group but like the therapist kind of
so like oh did you do your exercises
today and I'm like don't need your
advice or like okay I'll give you an
example like I have a friend and the
reason people react to her certain way
is because she's a [ __ ] and and and so
the therap she'd go to the therapist and
she'll tell a story and make herself out
to be the victim but I'm like no you
were rude to everybody in the room
that's why they don't like you right and
they're going and getting false advice
yeah yeah yeah yeah here all right
everybody get the likes up please uh I'm
I'm gonna get to a part where I like to
get it this gets a little juicy whenever
we get into these questions uh
um so these last questions uh it's y'all
are gonna kind of be judging each other
here uh we're gonna start
oh what's gonna be better here if you
say something then they might want yeah
let's start over here I want to see what
they say back to you okay so uh you
already know this game I want you to
make one critique about the people on
the other side of the panel the women on
the other side uh just give them one
relationship critique if you can give
them you know some type of advice to
make them better
first of all I would never take advice
from you sorry not sorry you wouldn't
take anything from anybody no I took
great advice from my therapist
period you're indoctrinated
you it could help yes yeah and everybody
like and like let him say his things and
nobody interrupt him because I just want
to hear I just want to hear what he says
and see y'all spaces
you
fingers
I got a point so she knows you can just
do this oh oh feminist yeah okay so you
the whole waiting and celibacy [ __ ]
that's not gonna work okay
seriously okay
that's a blunt answer but it means a lot
okay thank you I don't have anything to
say about you you've been playing a
mutual ground I think this that's fine I
feel like there needs to be one person
like you know oh I feel like there
needed to be one person that's not like
yeah so you were Faking It
not no not at all but I'm just not there
wasn't really any topics to be like you
just want to have sex no I don't I think
you do no I don't that's with who no he
just keeps eyeing me I've been eyeing
everybody I looked at you you I'm doing
like this to me yeah because from the
minute I saw you I knew that your career
was over with seriously I don't okay
um I just said I lost my job
makes you happy
all right go ahead and this debate made
me very happy today you were too
combative I'm an Aries
We're not gonna do that zodiac [ __ ]
she's a strong woman you don't that
zodiac I don't pull out the Taurus [ __ ]
I'm a Taurus
[Music]
she brought up the Zodiac we are talking
about that you need to get her not me
I like getting you though because you're
annoying
you were too combative well first of all
I'm lucky you need to wait your turn not
really
I've been elected Venezuela
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible